good morning Millennials Wow
we're back it's crazy how much has
happened in a week I mean I'm a brand
new person I'm a brand new and also a
very like old tired person but also
brand new from like reinvigoration that
can't toes brought to my life I have a
man's voice
it's beautiful I'm drinking tea honestly
yes this episode yeah this is friends
like people are loving it someone like I
forget where I was so we had a sexy boys
and I was like thank you sir
was it your uber driver no by the way so
I'm done with uber Claudia okay so I'm
done with uber I'm really done by the
way what if uber watches this and then
like finds out what you did and it's not
illegal it's not just frowned upon like
masturbating on an airplane not illegal
that is illegal exposing yourself in
public no no in the bathroom
Oh like you let's move the line from The
Hangover okay it's like thanks a lot of
sama okay so so oh yeah so I'm done with
uber like I'm making the change first of
all their prices keep going up second of
all they're making it so not helpful and
you about this uber scam
yeah TP gbg is all over it well I mean
everything about that number does is a
scam but now with their cancellation
fees and it's like even if the driver
cancels it's not considered it's an
undisputable
right which is just so crazy like I live
for a disputable cancellation fee like
but I love it because the amount that I
ride uber like I just always say that my
driver asked me to cancel and they never
dispute it because like why would I I
don't I don't want to be cancelling my
uber you know like I'm taking this uber
I'm doing the dog unless the cab comes
so like what I did with wag wag is so
expensive and I really liked it but I
found a walker on there that I love and
now we work offline and it's cheaper for
me because wag takes 20% anyway so
whatever so I've been waiting to get an
uber driver who's like clean has a nice
car we speak the same language like I'm
really just looking for like a premium
uber driver that I can take offline and
today I found it
congratulation and he's handsome as oh
I'm really excited for you but I'm
bursting with kam toast like no me Jimmy
but no but this morning like so once I
got in the car I had to ask him like if
he wanted to take this thing off line
and I really felt like I was asking
someone to homecoming it was like so
awkward and Margo bows Aaron marker was
making me feel even more awkward
counselor snitch counselor snitches czt
counselor he's three away by the way
total she was like just do it and I was
like she was being a counselor frozen
with fear in her track jacket my track
jackets we're gonna get we're gonna get
to counselors we're gonna get to
everything she did this weekend but you
guys for those of you who live under
Iraq how are you watching the show
because camp toast happened this weekend
and it was I mean it didn't just happen
you know like things just happened it
was it was a movement it was a movement
it was months years in the making and
all of our hard work pits anxiety oh my
god stress paid off on the rise we were
dreading it so much like we just didn't
know what and I feel like so many people
on their ride there it's they didn't
know what to expect we're coming alone
you're coming alone you're putting
together this group of people yes we
have so much in common we all love the
Kardashians in roni and the toasts but
like can we move past that
can you take it IRL can we take it I are
out and in the business world what we
did this weekend was [ __ ]
revolutionary we took a digital
experience I made it IRL experiential
and we should have a beard by our penis
at like VidCon run at a three-day like
you're in a bunk in the woods with
strangers most people came alone things
got real and it was it was so incredible
but you didn't like we wanted to do it
get it done and never do it again we
thought it was a chess wasn't gonna be
worth all the work that we put into it
and I literally can't wait for next
summer I've been thinking about my
friends like I miss Miranda my Brown so
much of her energy was infectious
Lorna Kimmy I miss her so much like I
just miss all my friends I even miss
Peyton who called me called the first
night and then apologized no but like
she didn't calm so much I follow her on
Instagram now and she's cutting down all
her trees for hurricane season because
she's lived in it
Charlotte is in North Carolina yeah she
was up at Charleston oh she does that
okay so it's hurricane season so I've
just been watching her at prepare Oh
farm and like just this is proof of the
power of the toasters is that a most
actually like a decent amount of our
listeners live in areas that are being
affected by the hurricane and they're
offering shelter to one another in the
groups nothing surprises me about
there's any more like ask so truth blaze
of like love affection and just like
human decency this weekend I'm obsessed
with the toasters and now I'm watching
and I'm seeing all these familiar names
Rene is watching gonna make Rene was the
MVP of camp toast it was like officially
ordained we had laminated awards that we
gave out at the end of the night because
we just wanted to like honor some people
who really put themselves out there it's
hard to come by yourself I mean it's
impossible I came with my my three
sisters and I was nervous I was still
like you know feeling awkward at time
and if you like we learned so much about
like what the jesters worn because like
Jackie and I really put in like a lot of
time and effort into the itinerary and
at the end of the day everyone just
wanted to drink and do karaoke and
that's all we need it rained the whole
time right so that's the thing like this
odds were stacked against us it rained
the entire time and all of our
activities were outside but like we
spent the whole day ziplining outside
jet skiing outside doing the ropes
course outside tubing outside and like
it was epic like the rain even made it
even better yeah it's just cuz it like
made it more epic like like and I can
only imagine like tubing when the lake
is flashing in your face and the rain is
coming down it's like everyone just
threw caution to the wind like didn't
care about what they looked like and it
was just it was such a good feeling it
was such a good feeling and now it just
makes me even more like stoked for next
year when like things go our way when
things go our way when now people know
exactly what they're getting themselves
in for a pasta bar a coffee bar a
carving station a roasted corn truck I'm
not over the roasted corn truck I keep
showing everyone that video corn beans
in the butter like the premium like you
understand you didn't take your wallet
at once though the bar was completely
open girls we gave out obviously if you
were a Kemp toast patron you got free
merch so you got shirts and really cute
water bottles people were filling up
their water bottles with a bottle and a
half of wine each we have multiple times
are wondering how much wine it takes to
fill up a Nalgene it's a bottle and a
half right and we just got our liquor
bill and we went through presumably 25
cases of white wine and rose a and an
entire truck of white wine 22 cases of
Rose ate only three cases of Pinot Noir
sorry Olivia yeah you tried your best
and then an entire truck of beer kegs
kegs on keg fun kegs and I'm just so the
toasters like first of all you guys can
drink so much and like rally like we
kept taking power the first
I like drink throughout because he
started raining and and once he starts
drinking it's like why why would you
stop and the next day I was really
struggling and I thought everyone else
would be too so we'd be like take it
easy no no they were up early we were
trying to make the schedule and we were
like what time should we make people up
like we did want to be annoying but like
we want to have a full day so we thought
9:00 was like the perfect time [ __ ]
were up at 6 a.m. hey anybody want to go
for a while I don't think anyone
actually woke up from my wake up cause
everyone was ready so I got up to do it
for nothing and the first night really
took it all out of me because that's
when I lost my voice due to my
performance of Celine Dion guests on and
then oh happy day from sister Rock cast
on took it all out of me took it if you
want to watch our performance of guest
on it's available on our GTV but like
you really didn't have to be there you
did and it also just feel like it was we
had a hundred campers the first year and
we were saying like the camp can
technically feel what 600 500 500 but I
don't think we would ever want to do
that much because like it's such like
the hundred people was perfect like I
know everyone's name I know everything
about everyone like I know where they're
from I know their life and like I really
feel like it was just the perfect amount
but we have to make it more to go so
many times we are a business and we're
we're a growing brand and we didn't lose
money on this venture but it doesn't
matter and if we were going on Shark
Tank like having hundred people two
years in a row isn't impressive
grow gotta grow is impressive I keep
thinking about our business like in
terms of what the Sharks would say
Jackie that's so weird they would
literally flip for us totally because I
keep thinking about that because I heard
a rumor that Richard Branson lives in
the neighborhood that I just moved into
yeah so he it's I got a firm religious I
keep thinking what if I run into him and
I say first of all I loved you on Shark
Tank
second of all here's my pitch I run a
business called the morning javis beard
of the fastest growing digital morning
show and the only digital morning show
our concept it's not revolutionary
it's our audience that makes us what we
are we are a community of millennial
females and a couple men 3 to be
specific 3
we had three men that Kim chose they had
their own bunk they became best friends
for life like it was so epic and they
contributed so much and if you're a man
and you're unsure about coming to camp
toast it is the place for you for sure
yeah regardless of sexual orientation
like I really felt like when we first
started I was like girls only girls only
but that and obviously gays are included
than that but now I'm just like anyone
who wants to come to camp toast this is
exactly what I said can
just is what you make it so you come
with an attitude you come with a good
time come with your boyfriend Guerra
it's like we'll give you your own bunk
so you can have sex like yes just it's
what you make if you want to come with
your man you can have your own bunk and
you can do it that way but so many of
the girls that came like Lauren Hans we
were talking and I was like an exterior
like for your husband like you guys can
have your own bunk and he can like
experience it she's like no cuz she like
had the most amazing time just like
being herself and just like coming out
of her shell and like sometimes and
sometimes it's better to like come alone
put yourself out there yes it's scary
but like it's so worth it in the end we
were gonna have been Anzac calm and then
we were like hell no like we really just
wanted like the female energy and like
the and also like I was so already so
spread thin between like because I was
saying I'm an owner Jamie we're camp
directors camp counselors and campers at
the same time like there there was so
much work for us so everybody wore
generals there was so much work for us
to be doing at all times like I couldn't
think about like someone else who wasn't
who wouldn't have fit into the itinerary
totally like and been like let's say
yeah and I'd be like been running a
[ __ ] camp here right and like the two
of them sleeping on those beds that we
slept on that they would Jackie and I
didn't put much thought into our beds
and now I'm wishing that we did because
I came back a sore woman from
capture-the-flag couldn't walk I was so
grateful that it was raining outside cuz
I was using an umbrella as a cane and
like without like looking suspicious no
we really needed to just bring with me
you just came with the basics like a
sheet and a blanket
you need an egg crate yeah oh my god
next year I'm doing it so differently
I'm buying like a featherbed deluxe
supreme like you guys you have to invest
in sleep I'm learning that now and the
more that I think about it the more that
I think this camp concept is [ __ ]
brilliant and I know people are gonna
start copying us and that's fine
imitation is the most sincere form of
flattery just don't forget to do it at
first I really feel like in five summers
like it's gonna be a million dollar
business it's not even about the
business it's just about like the
experience but like from the shark tank
point of view like it's gonna be yeah
this is just the beginning of something
so exciting we're already planning camp
to us 2019 because so many people were
so upset like that they missed it
like please we gave you enough time but
I think more than we're gonna keep
talking about it in June we're gonna
give you eight to ten months notice cuz
we're already working on camp trust 2019
mark your calendars hopefully Memorial
Day weekend May 20 19 I don't wanna hear
an excuse I'm giving you a Monday also
uses other than it being sold out yeah
ah
just so it's saying and it's like so
like
the Roman elf initially it's like our
dream come true oh my god cuz we [ __ ]
love camp and like it's inappropriate to
go back as a 25 year old married woman
but like on okay right and like but
going for a weekend with all of your
online friends acceptable also what we
need to figure out is we need to just
hire a couple straight men to just like
exist because there were about three or
four straight men who worked for the
camp that were like our age and see the
joys and there were only two that were
six people and the toasters that were
just like cooped up with girls all
weekend like by the end we're just like
ready for some action yeah and these two
dudes like had that weekend of their
lives
I know perfect no I know for a fact so I
don't know what the best because I don't
want people to come to camp to us like
just to get like guys to come like just
thinking that they're gonna get late cuz
it's like we don't need you until like
the end of the night the poor bartenders
who were both married like one of them
got locked in a truck and was like take
me away look I'm married so we need to
like bring in some fresh meat we'll have
to figure out what the strategy is for
nah we just need to hire straight men -
just like exist yeah where it's like you
could make me fill out an application
let's be bachelor yeah it's literally
the back you have to figure it out but
it's not you're in paradise because
there's a lot of options speaking of
bachelor in paradise we're gonna get to
all of it all of that at the end of the
show cuz there is a lot to break down
but anyways I just want to say a big
thank you to everyone to who came to
camp to us and take took a chance on
some unknown camp directors because it
was so worth it and I hope you like
raita streaming our lives I will forever
be indebted to the hundred people who
took a chance spent their hard-earned
money on something they knew nothing
about like did they know there was gonna
be an omelet station every morning and a
pasta station conversation at night no
that was just an added bonus but they
spent their money on like literally and
experience they knew nothing about and
I'll be forever grateful and I know that
they feel like they got their money's
worth but like I just I can't thank
those girls enough like we will forever
be bonded by that experience like I are
the most amazing time the most amazing
time someone asked if it's a good place
for stale toasters and Renee I need you
in there letting everyone know so we're
gonna hang who won MVP shmita speech
like literally made me want to cry of
course everyone made me I did nothing
and it's up crying and it was like when
I came home I was like drained
physically and emotionally because I was
just like so emotional I was trying to
tell Ben I'm like I can't even talk no
like you just had to be there no I
didn't tell I was just like all I could
say is like you can't even believe it
was so crazy like I'm just like showing
him videos
like I can't but Rene was our sale
toaster she's a part of the Seattle
toasters which is the older toasters
group and is just so funny cuz like when
everyone was showing up they're like I'm
the oldest person here I'm like picture
35 like everyone was just like so like
concerned about their age and then by
the time they left they were like I
literally didn't even think of it like I
had no clue how old anyone was but Rene
was like I'm a part of a group and
they're all so jealous but they were so
nervous to come because they thought
they wouldn't be accepted and she was
like thank you to all these girls for
like not making me think about my age
even once like I just I felt like one of
the girls which is what you are and she
was like I got married when I was 19 had
kids when I was 20 21 22 and I never got
to experience at college or being a
sardine it's like this is my time and
she was just like and I'm like same
[ __ ] I got married when I was 21 like I
was in a sorority this is my time except
like I drink a lot all the time but you
know but it because it's your tits still
in your time because of the toasters
but anyways Rene is a grandma and a
sunday-school teacher and I love her so
much [ __ ] Rene's watching she is
watching him so that's for everyone no
one cared at all there was just
something else about kam toast was the
birth of counselor snitch it was just a
figure that we never knew that we needed
in our life Jackie put on this bit like
the whole [ __ ] weekend where Margot
mr. counselor because the second day the
first full day of camp toast Margot
shows up to breakfast like looking like
a straight up counselor I was about
sorry yes and I just could like she was
wearing her counselor shorts like the
Nike running shorts her cam to assured
her hair and a pony like and she was a
counselor so all weekend and this is
what camera stood in their counselors
they're like counselor counselor is it
rain like asking like by Fred what's for
dinner counselor I think they have like
the keys to the universe and they know
everything counselor when they're
hungover counselor are you sick
no they're so [ __ ] annoying so that
was Jackie the whole weekend like every
time she needed something counselor
snitch and it was funny like then it got
annoying it was so funny so funny in my
head I just like had this whole like
written out anyways we came home she
still accounts her in the her track Jack
you're gonna answer over there I'm
forever grateful for Camco superb ring
yes for so many things a conic figure
that we didn't know that we needed in
our lives and the camp does Facebook
creep like you'd think that camp is over
that like it's done but now that that
video I mean that group is like so let
they're putting a meet up their meeting
of Nashville they're going to Vegas
January we gotta go also what was your
like favorite part of like one moment
that was a big part I think I mean fried
the campfire the first night was my
favorite like one of my favorite major
ones it was the only time that I drank
so I was like really having fun and to
I've had so many also good
heart-to-hearts with people and like I'm
not a big heart to heart you know it's
even more meaningful when I'm there was
more swords were so good this more
sorsogon and was just like so campy and
I felt like it was just like everyone
was really in it and like people were
still arriving and everyone just got
into it immediately and it was like just
a smash success from the jump and then
like the day of activity you need to of
like when we were on that tube when your
tubing me you in council snitch and we
were just laughing crying like kids died
and that's by the way that exact moment
was the impetus behind doing this whole
thing cuz we're like why do you have to
be a kid to enjoy like those like pure
joy childlike moments we were on the
back of that tube going 100 miles an
hour
literally hysterically laughing our legs
were in the air like that was just the
essence like a cantos pure joy and it's
like you don't get like these days you
have to either like get a table out of
club or like something extreme to like
have fun where it's like this is like
you're just breaking life down to its
essentials it's so nature laughter
alcohol but you know it's made from corn
optional so it's it's from the earth
yeah and it was just such a joyous
experience without having to like
manufacture very much late I had two
more moments I want to highlight one is
color war because it was absolutely
buggy mild and we got out of control
we listened because it was team Jackie
versus team Claudia and one of the games
that we played a camp is capture the
flag which it's a different version of
capture the flag but the essence you
have to capture the flag and it got out
of control
like everyone was getting out of control
meet specifically and that's really
where he lost my voice and I just didn't
need to take this moment to apologize to
have an the child errs because I made
her cry because I called her a big
[ __ ] cheater it was just like in the
heat like she was cheating but but you
know this morning we can't get back into
this I think the whole time we were
playing you're accusing our team of
cheating and it's like with that we're
not like we weren't cheating me it was
her and then we were on the same side
because I wasn't accusing your team of
cheating it was like there were rules
and no one is following them because
they judge you or there
whirring rules and so it was like
technically or not cheating if this
isn't a rule but it shouldn't be okay
right so like I do it was real you guys
like it's funny now sort of it was so
intense and then I was raining it
started pouring so we had to stop
playing cuz like we didn't want a torn
ACL cuz that would suck ass and so we
moved inside to play dodgeball which was
much more you would think dad twelve
agree more intense think it was very
relaxed and we had learned our lesson I
sat out like I took the emotions out of
it like I was good and because like it
is usually a fat camp like the dodge
balls were very small and frail and if
you got pegged by one like it didn't
hurt at all and you couldn't throw them
very hard so yeah it was okay it was all
okay it was okay I won in the end which
like I just love it's cuz I like I lost
my voice like for something for a cause
yeah and then I got to crowd surf which
is my dream
I've never crowd surfed oh yeah that's
fun yeah have you ever I don't know I
should have crossed hurt on my wedding
totally I'm doing like wedding planning
now and like there's just so much so
much like it's like so many thoughts you
have to have like about just like what
your vehicle scenarios what your vibe in
life is it's like any to a second night
by the way no matter what you decide
just because you're deciding it in like
a high tense time like it's I'm in here
and it's like the color said I'm
choosing it's like those aren't my
colors they're like what's your poem I
don't know no but like my palette isn't
like you would think my palette is like
cleany vibes only pink but like that's
not what I'm doing just cuz like it
doesn't make sense yeah cuz I'm not like
Lisa I'm not getting married to Lisa
Vanderpump right no no it's like we're
Elwood's like it's hard right like I'm
getting married to a man so I have to
think about these things but I mean you
know she'd just become lesbians her hats
just so we can get the wedding's that we
want totally or just like Sue Sylvester
marry yourself yeah oh so epic she was
on to something to us anyways I think
we'll come back to camp toast like all
the time and if you were there I love
you so much I will remember you forever
and if you post premium content on
Instagram I will follow you because I'm
loving just knowing what the toasters
are doing in their downtime like if Alex
Samantha Wayne and it's just like oh
we're on the web of my life
Samantha Wayne if you're watching like
the hero of Pentos secure the unsung
hero of camp toast I could quote her but
I won't
don't anyways camcos 2.0 tickets will be
going on sale like in the next month
just keep your eye out for them because
I really think they're gonna fly off the
shelves because it was that
proof of concept the concept was proven
the pasta bar was premium the price was
justified even more so yet but if you
were complaining about the price then
Curtis chrono has it's going up because
we under commend we under charge that's
the way business works and also we under
charge supply demand supply yeah shark
tank
wit shark if you could have a deal with
any shark we've said this twice now it
depends on what my business is but this
business actually I'm gonna go Mark
Cuban cuz he's big on tech and and he's
an innovator I was just gonna say mark
cuz he's tech boy but it depends like if
I was making a beverage tomorrow home
right but you're not you're not making a
beverage no for the toast mark sure sure
okay are you ready to get into the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast I am thank you so
much for asking
you're welcome sister we have so many
stories today there's so many bachelor
pad s stories that will all be grouped
under group 5 ok but for now we're
starting with Story number 1 Kylie
Jenner on the cover of Glamour being the
essence of Glamour Kylie Jenner claims
she doesn't care how pregnancy changed
her body because she's an amazing the
feminist hero we didn't ask for but we
definitely deserves we did we don't even
deserve
honestly were the were the worst Kylie
Jenner is loving the skin she's in the
Keeping Up with the Kardashians star
opened up about her body has changed
since giving birth during an interview
with Glamour UK quote pregnancy
completely changed my body at a super
young age she told the magazine but I
really don't care this isn't the first
time the makeup mogul has discussed her
body since welcoming stormy Webster the
new mom talked about the topic earlier
this summer during the YouTube video
with her bestie Jordan Jordan woods
while the Kylie cosmetics head said
people assumed she was able to quote
bounce back super fast after giving
birth and that everything was perfect
she also acknowledged that people can
get the wrong idea on Instagram totally
in addition she said going through these
changes at such a young age can be
physically mentally and emotionally a
challenge although she also described
her experience as a quote beautiful
thing so I just I mean I love her so
much she looked incredible on the cover
of Glamour her like no makeup makeup
look is so stunning like when her
freckles show through I just love her
and I feel like ever since becoming mom
she's really turning it down I'm like
the Botox the makeup and she's just
looking so she said
being her true self inside and out but
you know what's confusing to me it's
like she's still in the cover of like
glamour UK like what's wrong with like
she should be on the cover of Vogue like
truly totally on a popularity level on a
success level like she is all of it she
should be on the cover I'll and a cover
of Vogue like I would go buy it
glamour you at best like she's any
glamour UK it's still very prestigious
and they their show is international but
they live in America she should be on
the cover of Vogue September issue I'm
totally next year who was on the cover
of me today and it was like really cool
come out yes wasn't sue now Lady Gaga's
on the October issue I saw that I mean I
cannot [ __ ] wait for his daughters
born last night I mean it started
swearing to come out and last night I
was at a Russian at dinner and like
people were talking about it was like an
older band a younger crowd like people
were just saying like like giving [ __ ]
on it surimi
yeah it's come out three times ready
it's a good movie that keeps getting
remade Barbra Streisand's in a Judy
Garland was in it like that's so cool
yeah so it's like first of all Lady
Gaga's speaks for the town of our
generation I'm fine with that Bradley
Cooper as well I'm fine with that like I
hate my people [ __ ] I'm like Millennials
doing stuff like this alone
leave us alone then like we're you
[ __ ] on it when Barbra Streisand
remade it I'm sure they were actually
you think and I mean you guys it's like
you have to take this all with a grain
of salt because we're incapable of
coming up with an original idea
seeing as how everyone has just copies
the morning toast and remakes shows that
stocked back in their heyday and by the
way you know those was you know at least
let's make a movie that was good enough
to be made three times and let's choose
some good stars where I'm very here for
Lady Gaga her acting debut I've heard
the movie is phenomenal really and
honestly I'm like majorly regretting not
filling out that paperwork for sag a
couple months ago because if you're
inside you get movies early and like the
paperwork was so much and the fee was
$3,000 and I just like wasn't doing it
but if I was I would be able to be
watching a star was born right now so
like maybe it was I want to go to the
theater and have the big the big
experience it really is so different
watching the movie in theaters and
watching it at home I still need to see
crazy magicians i J I saw it last week
and it's so good like the level of
detail glamour everything romance like
Beauty oh my god we need to talk about
Sarah Burgess is loser did you see that
yes I did
okay that's alyssum are gonna write it
down and we need to do polka king but
we'll do that I don't think anyone watch
it yeah I didn't see one thing guys well
I mean there was Kantos it was very busy
week the toast movie of the week
ongoing until next week it is the Polka
king please watch it because it's so
[ __ ] there's a thread in the morning
toasters about the movie Ciara Burgess
and it is on point because I didn't
watch the threat I didn't any girl was
like Sara burgesses loser was so much
better to all them to all the boys
before
first of all everyone is agreed in the
poor girl that should interpose but you
didn't it's just in firm in her opinions
and of you but then people just were
doing analysis on it and it's important
we'll talk about it we'll talk about it
but it's like here's the thing we get no
good movies ever like even though
there's no ROM comes in theaters anymore
that's not a demographic ever since
Katherine Heigl just like murdered it
should you stop working since she
stopped working like there's no more
wrong comes whatever now we get movies
like [ __ ] table 19
whatever oh my god I just watch that
movie I think that's the version of like
today's right so like there's three
rom-coms that have come out on Netflix
and they're all amazing I'm tired of
comparing them each one has to be better
in the next show shoot all the boys I
love it's like it's better than kissing
with kitties yeah no they're all really
good and I you like Sierra Burgess is a
loser there were a couple things I
didn't that didn't like add up for me
but I enjoyed it and that girl we need
will talk about it Veronica the unsung
hero falls Ben I was like Ben follow her
back right now she deserves
well her I don't know about her but
Veronica like deserved everything okay
we'll talk about it okay
back to the stories anyways kylie is out
here just being the feminist see room
diff feminist hero that we need and like
and this is just like it's so comforting
to hear because it's like yes she has an
amazing body but we also all did see
pictures like from Coachella and shakily
admit such as students or pictures
confirmed like and it's just it's so
refreshing it's so refreshing and no one
will give her like the credit that she
deserves and everyone things like that
the Kardashians are sending a feminist
feminism back two decades on all that
[ __ ] but like they have done more
for women's bodies in the past ten years
than anyone then Atkins has you know
together it's just like no one gives
them credit and people say like their
girls with no talent they use their
bodies blah blah blah but like here they
are like being talking so candidly about
something so many people are ashamed of
like please I'm so here for it when my
body changes I'm gonna embrace the [ __ ]
out of it because Kylie did did you see
their new show on Facebook watch what
the hell is it like it's it's basically
there's no chance
put together it's basically the morning
toast Kardashian size is it like it's
why are they have a show on Facebook
watch you have one on e you you get a
show on Facebook watch so you can get a
show on me it's not the other way around
those who can't get shows on e get shows
on Facebook watch right so like what are
Y you don't need another show we're good
except I watch a movie I was laughing a
little bit next story more generous
Brandon Jenner and Leah Jenner split
after 14 years together
so wait that was shocked and also their
statement was really weird
oh I mean it was sweet but it was weird
because this is what they said quote
after celebrating 14 beautiful years
together we have lovingly come to the
decision to end the romantic aspect of
our relationship
we are deeply proud of the life we've
cultivated together and are truly
grateful for the bond of friendship we
hold and cherish today it is stronger
than ever even though we have chosen to
separate as a couple we still love each
other one another very very much and
remain a major major part of each
other's lives as best friends family and
loving parents to our daughter so it's
like they're still likes like they seem
like a unity they always have they
always well they have the exact same
interest they're business related so
it's like okay so the only thing that
was lost was the romance but like how do
you how bad could it be well so the rest
sounds this segment was so weird because
I've heard it before
and it's literally word-for-word from
logics statement about his wife and
Chris Pratt and Anna Faris they're
they're removing the romantic aspect of
their religion that's just so weird to
me because if you have the rest of this
like the romance should be your best
friends partners business partners
parents and you're like so in sync and
just like the romance is gonna go to
dinner like it doesn't make sense like
this is like this I'm not buying this
like this isn't a legitimate excuse for
divorce okay you have all those things
that's a pretty good marriage really but
these statements are never like no but
I'm saying like if you guys yes you off
the hook this type of thing Juwan and
Channing Tatum made the same one right
if you think that that gets you off the
hook and that explains something it
doesn't because so many people in this
world would kill to have a relationship
like you're describing
yeah but also you don't know what goes
on behind closed doors right know what
I'm saying so it's not this way so and
I'm saying but this isn't like the
judges that's just Hollywood they were
loose statements that it's all just lies
no but so much you know if you're gonna
go to the trouble of releasing a
statement like at least give something
that it's like people can relate to we
can understand how this could
have like no falling apart this could be
like a horrible thing to say but like do
you think it's Caitlin's fault at the
family's been through so much like how
can any relationship survive um I was
actually thinking the same thing like
she's been through she was like brandon
has been through so much in his life but
recently we've seen their remember when
they were trying like making them happen
on the show and by the way it works this
isn't the worst sight you don't have
over a million lowers they're like so
Instagram they're so like insurance in
the field tumblr um so but like these
two just seemed like made for each other
like she like Adam and Eve you know made
from the rain no this was very shocking
so there it's just and I don't think
they're famous enough but I could use
some blinds here I don't think they're
famous enough there's a bunch what is it
because it just came out now you're
making allegations say no saying what's
enough it's alleged what is the what do
you want to read the blind where's there
where I beloved Lee says that this be -
celebrity officering reality star came
out to his wife oh and that's why they
split out but they'll never say it okay
okay that would be that would be as
something I could understand that must
be hard for Leah any CB - that's very
high that's very high but they do have a
million and their last name yeah and
these like it'll change your name I bet
you never I would never change my name
at Carter Jenner no Claudia does
something better yeah and then you have
to change they change okay and you would
then they become like Russian right and
then you could also meet the audio
things happen da da da da she loved it
Daria - um are you ready for the next
story because it's wild and it's a
little bit of world news coming out of
CNN ooh the woman who helped Elizabeth
kidnap Elizabeth Smart will be released
from prison are you okay
no you understand I'm not okay well okay
well born between the years of 1991 and
1994 are not okay when Jackie when we
were kids and this story came out like
it shook America to the core like first
cuz it was like first of all these
stories never have happy endings so like
everyone was along for the ride that she
went missing they investigated they
her alive like we were there for it all
and when it was happening like Jackie
was not okay Jackie used to go
downstairs in her house when we lived in
a house be the big house there was like
a million doors in the back Jackie would
lock every door before bed like this
story I was like eight years old I was
setting the alarm yeah not because no
one else would because I could I had to
do it before I went to sleep or else I
wouldn't see it was so crazy I lost him
I wonder how many like years of life I
lost in sleep know how many wrinkle
lines on your forehead or due to
Elizabeth Smart yeah well do two Wanda
Sykes this dumb [ __ ] and Laura Mitchell
Jackie Sykes is my favorite her name I
haven't ever seen the Wanda Sykes video
I'm sorry where she's prank calls the
garage about the dump in her car please
go look into it is her name is Wanda bar
Z but I only know one Wanda it was near
the good name once a site whose greatest
role in monster-in-law Wanda Sykes is
such an underrated comedian I [ __ ]
love her I totally agree I'm so sorry
Wanda I think this will probably get
back to her cuz everything what the
toast gets back to everyone if you
haven't seen Wanda Sykes turn in my car
it's not even a video you have to be
listen to the audio my friend Ames
showed it to me oh my god it's like what
we used to listen to it on what LimeWire
we'd be like download never not make
back when Elizabeth Smart was kidnapped
yeah okay so the woman's getting out
here's the story Elizabeth Smart said
Tuesday that the Utah parole board's
decision to release one of the people
who abducted her was surprising and
quote incomprehensible Wanda Eileen bars
he wasn't expected to be released for at
least another five years however the
Utah Board of Pardons and Paroles said
it hadn't credited her sentence in the
state system with the time she served in
federal prison as such bars II now 72
will leave prison on September 19th
that's so soon
so she apart it's like OJ like nothing
surprises me anymore but why don't
parole people doing their job
this is horrible hybl oh my god and for
all of you out there and there are so
many like people my age I don't know but
because Elizabeth Smart I think she was
born my turning shoe so she's my age
like we were shook to the core by the
story it shaped our whole lives like and
even after she was found like it didn't
make it any better like no because he's
that guy that the mom invited into the
house to anyone could catch in the
middle of the night while sleeping with
their sister and then it's like I didn't
want to sleep with my sister because
like what if he took my sister like
right that's
work then like you're responsible right
we're like could I could probably hack
it better than a snitch
totally oh my god this is horrible like
I did you think years because when
people go to prison like you basically
like they're gone it's like by but it's
like they're not they could get out
Oh Jay Oh Jay that was like technically
the parole board did their job because
he wasn't in jail for prison I need for
murder right where he's in for stealing
memorabilia where's at least how long
how long do you need to go to prison for
what for stealing memorable and at least
he went to prison at all right so no but
she's in prison for what she did and
it's crazy that like kidnapping
Elizabeth Smart was born in 1987 really
yeah because she was like 7 years old
when she got I don't know why it just
relates to her so much I thought because
her story happened at your coming-of-age
yeah yeah for sure
it was such a wild time in America and
if I ever seen here that she's like
famous do you know no but like she's
doing the most with her platform like
she's really like committed to her faith
and she's like it's so crazy the worst
possible thing in her like in life
happened to her and all she does is like
give back and like go on missions and
like just want to be a better person
like help change the world like weird
like how would you categorize Elizabeth
smart like famous kid not be like it's
just weird yeah but there are other
people like that like Patty Hearst
remember actually no that happened way
before we were at Loyola jamun she's
dead so like right but then they're also
like famous murderers accused when Anna
Knox also like who killed Germany the
brother I think I can't believe we still
don't know I know and it's like only God
knows and the person who like who did it
totally I just I think that like when we
all die we're glad and we find out all
the things like we find out who Solange
and jay-z talking about the elevator
like with me find out yeah you can ask
fake any question what what happened
that never ever learned around [ __ ]
Amana knocks do it I don't really care
about Anna knocks like I don't know what
I'm having to you about documentary no I
did but like Casey Anthony she totally
did it oh that I don't eat answers to I
wouldn't waste my question on that I
don't think you get one I think you like
find out all the answers to the universe
but say you only got three questions
Oh cheesy even though like I feel like I
know but yeah no one really knows
this is chewy yeah okay and also like
this were so not that high but like
there's so many podcasts about like
conspiracies and murders and all this
stuff and it's like let's leave that to
them you know this is not the place for
it goes into Darren carps Martinez in
murder right but she thinks every time
she comes on the show I asked her who
killed Dominic
Jessica she has some new information and
she I think she goes like she won't say
it especially not on her show cuz like
they're an oxygen show and you can't
just like just to throw out random
accusations but I think she's gone
brother on this one who okay our fourth
story in a little bit more World News
that's just really exciting from all
brands and space and of course Elon Musk
there for corporate sponsors could help
NASA keep pace with private space
companies doesn't sound like an
interesting headline little space
exploration ain't cheap even if you're
funded by one of the richest countries
on earth to raise some extra cash NASA
Administrator Jim Briton Stein says the
Space Agency will start looking into
whether corporate sponsors can by naming
rights or brand placements for its space
craft or whether astronauts could appear
in commercials like the rocket that goes
to Mars could be called like the Elon
Musk or the morning toast like we could
buy how much the brand I mean they need
like milli probably billions but like
Amazon could be up by the rocket that
launches into space so Apple they will
we're just a pit like an Apple does
their own competition it's yeah I'm
really late I guess would be between
Amazon and Apple because as we reported
you're both willing they're both out in
trillion so I guess think it's fair a
billion on this I think I'm I'm done
with you I'm asked now why I lost like
I've lost her open and he's out of
control I haven't and especially like we
were talking this weekend someone from
the toast because they're obviously like
the most prominent members of society
works at SpaceX listen nobody's worried
Elon spine the kids are all right I
don't know I'm not getting good vibes
usually that Jeff I'm smoking a joint on
the Joe Rogan podcast yeah but what is
the Joe Rogan I don't know but it's
always someone in our category and
everyone's always going on it we should
probably listen to it like it'd be I'd
be curious to hear one moment what is
number one it will things in our
category then it's correct right you
know it's just everyone's always going
out of it I'm like why haven't we met
him it I mean if he lawns on it like I
understand if we need to like prove
ourselves a little more before we're on
it
that's true like he's going to Mars and
we're going to the Poconos
sounds more prestigious to me I totally
agree
anyways I think that's pretty cool like
NASA like private and public coming
together like NASA confuses me is it
company we discovered it's the
government and that's why I think what
Tesla does is really cool because it's
like from what I understand it's private
and there was a republic but it was no
but there it's private English like it's
it's not it's it's not government and
when the government does stuff it's
always like slow versus legit more
expensive but NASA's legit as hell but
they require a lot of money but you know
what I would have I'm happy to know that
some of my taxes go to an asset I feel
like [ __ ] or [ __ ] like no like I'm more
than happy for my taxes to NASA yeah but
like can I I look at the other taxes oh
my god ID to pay my taxes
oh my oh you're gonna say you have to
pay times like I do because I'm drinking
tea today because my boys know anyways I
look forward to seeing what corporate
sponsors and also I was reading like
basically NASA has been so averse to
private companies in the past even when
talking about MMS they would call them
candy-covered chocolates like they would
never give any brand play but now like
the brand is in play it which is very
exciting for many brands came to go to
chocolate I wonder it's like a foreign
company could by the name def not know
this is American belt I'm an American
made Debbie they'll be crazy it's like
BMW that that would be a BMW rocket
it'll be cool though that would be I'm
here for anyone win any catalog and
agend cheap Ford any brand that wants to
contribute to our space exploration why
not let's go we got to beat the Russians
more people on Mars and less people on
earth
we got an election traffic there's no
traffic on Mars no but so I couldn't I
couldn't move I'm too much of a homebody
I would be too homesick for her I would
need it egg crate on Mars I feel like
but with all the gravity like you
wouldn't even that's true i legit have
I'm so skinny I don't weigh anything on
Mars no you wouldn't even have to like
worry about weight honestly what are we
still doing here also I have the
craziest bruises from cam toast like a
color of bruise I've never had before
and I just want to thank my sister
Claudia for it I did give it to her she
did and I definitely accidentally with
it a little
Allie's Hill Golf Cart X I just I made
like a little sharp turn on the golf
cart and Jackie dug into my side and the
Jackie was screaming so right to stop in
the middle of a hill
and then we were going uphill and then
once I press on the gas it was it was
bad I get honest ly it gives me the
biggest pitch I can't even imagine that
was I think about that all the time how
I could have killed all my sisters and
Zoey squirtle but we did it and we're
all here to tell the tale of the amazing
weekend at camp toast but we almost
weren't okay now it's time for the
bachelor in paradise recap there are
three news stories that have emerged
this morning and the first one I don't
even know which one is more shocking
than next the first one I think is the
most shocking
wait it's 11:11 English always the same
way you just wish for more tangible
items you like I hope a Gucci bag
arrives on my doorstep I hope like good
poops today you know right and then
you'll know actually good is still
subjective right it's like soft or hard
totally Gucci Gucci please no
counterfeits you guys okay bachelor in
heroin no Kevin booth bachelor in
paradise is Jordan Kimball is a
blindsided by Jenna Cooper's alleged
affair quote I feel sick
do you do you know this story no money
on explain it to me it is actually
shocking so they've got engaged
they got heat on bachelor in paradise
they'd like for him it was love at first
sight for her she like you know had to
play with Benoit's back little French
baguette for a little bit then came back
to Jordan and now someone in Jenna's
life sent text messages to reality Steve
of course like people his wait too
classy to publish the text messages so
make sure we pull them up and basically
she was like dating someone before she
went on the show she went on the show
and now the guys watching the episodes
with Jordan they're professing her love
for each other and she sends this him
this whole long Magilla like good
morning hand so I'm like I'm so sorry
for what you've been seeing on the show
this week like just no I don't like
Jordan let alone love him like I'm just
doing this for my business you know how
much I need the money like when it's all
over like I'll end it in a way that
makes him look bad don't worry and it's
like he just went on like they had a
wedding date he's so like he's the
purest man that's what I said on the
show and the way so and then like this
these text messages came out on reality
Steve yesterday morning and he found out
about it like literally in his car and
then like pmags and called him and he
literally just starts rambling this
somebody said the Jordan Jordan Jenna
said these are not true please respect
my privacy I'm working I'm focusing on
my relationship wait but the toasters
did do a deep dive into the text
messages and they saw they'll exhumed in
that like they look layered
and that it could be Photoshop that's
all some I once saw the twisters you a
deep dive on something and where they
found their layers of between and it was
a totally legitimate also like it's
gonna make a big text message it's just
like make it on your phone a screenshot
oh right I I so I don't I'm not buying
those that period Jordan said it's quote
it felt like a body drop I got taken
down I'm weak in the knees and I feel
like I have rocks in my stomach
I'm and I don't want to read her
statement and not even vivid time day on
Monday I saw something that someone
posted on Twitter that somebody was
gonna be roasted the next night says
Campbell reality Steven said that Jenna
called me and said she was very anxious
about this Twitter post I talked to her
in the middle of the night last night I
said don't hide yourself up don't worry
you have nothing to worry about I tried
to calm her down I went back to bed for
a few hours woke up had my coffee and
she called me again and said she was
feeling anxious and sick to her stomach
she's in New York I told her to keep
calm I thought she was just being
nervous for no reason then I was driving
back to Central Florida for Miami and I
started getting calls from cast mates
like Chris I started getting screenshot
sent to me I didn't know what to think I
sat in my seat I know my Jenna and I
read those texts and my heart I know
it's her she was saying she didn't do it
but hinting towards the fact that
there's a possibility that had happened
in all reality I don't expect her to own
it and honestly I totally like can see
that like if I read text like I can if
someone showed me it's my own scent like
you know how someone said I guess I
didn't just say Allah right or like no I
feel like that's something that totally
you know and the way they use like
punctuation the words they use good
morning comma hand sound like I'm sure
she said that but it's like a very weird
specific thing to say right and so this
is totally and saying she's a con artist
like she has all these men like invested
in her she's like a master manipulator
for her business which like is what's
her business well her Instagram handle
is Jenna Cooper fit so I'm assuming
she's a trainer um good loan but like I
don't know how going on back to him
paradise I mean like drunk and stupid
the whole time like really helps promote
your business and I'm so glad that she's
being aired as you drive because so many
people on the bachelor duo on for the
wrong reasons for AB but and now they're
the right reasons just to promote your
business maybe fall in love cool she's
so blatant about and she was just so
blatant and like
really just chose like the nicest guy
and just used him but she's kind of
smart because when we came into the show
like he was the devil and everything he
did was wrong so that no matter what
happened she was gonna look like the
nice sweet blonde and he's gonna end up
the male model totally no it's like
making a lot of sense like why she chose
him and also because he was ride-or-die
for her even when she was going on dates
with other guys he was always there
first so if she wanted to get engaged in
the end like he was the perfect person
because like he was so in love with her
so are they engaged so um I mean like it
was unclear at the time that people
spoke see Jordan but I would imagine
last night is was the reunion yeah and
we only did was filmed a few weeks ago
he asked Chris Howard in a Chris
Harrison to officiate their wedding at
June 9th which would have been the start
of the next season in paradise like he
was down to get married choosing like
caterers like and he had said so many
times on the show like he only is gonna
propose once in his life Washington
Washington DC the capital is calling me
hello mr. president sir courting okay to
make sure like you know it's always spam
at Washington DC but they want you to
think that the Trump Trump or like the
Secretary of State Condoleezza
snitcher saying mrs. Clinton correct
future say or maybe it's mrs. glitz yes
anyways this is really like actually so
crazy and the fact that it was posted on
reality Steve and then snitch and I were
talking last night and she was like how
come this isn't on a news like where is
it I was like well they like they regard
the reality Steve like the morning toast
like they never give it the shine that
it deserves
but because Jordan commented on them
like now it's a story now it's on E news
now it's everywhere and like holy I
never done so often but like because the
the book was closed on it last night at
the finale I never thought anyone would
address it and like that it would just
go the way that's why they should you
live yes right and like the fact that
all this happened and then the reunion
didn't address it but there's it's not
they're not in tune with what's
necessary even though they only film the
ring and a few weeks ago they're trying
to keep it as close to reality as I mean
they [ __ ] film bachelor in paradise
for three weeks and then they're also
gonna film the reunion three weeks out
like so much happens in such a short
amount of time yeah like it's so crazy
so the reunion last night like baby came
on last week and it's like crazy we
never even got to like recap it because
then camp toast happened and she said
like so much crazy should happen to
three Union and there was some crazy
[ __ ] like first of all Camille broke up
with Annalise like on air which is like
the whole time watching them
Camille and Emily's are those girls
Camille is a man oh okay and il oh
commit it's like the social media
whatever and then I actually went to his
profile and he has a lot of followers
and he's like a model and so at first I
thought it was just like a random guy on
the show so like Annalise like begging
him to date her like made sense but like
he's like with Wilhelmina he like walked
in Fashion Week oh wow yeah so he's kind
of like gonna be a hard one to nail down
so she shows clearly she chose the wrong
guy anyways he broke up with her on the
show which was like kind of sad for her
because all she wants us to be married
and like she would literally marry but
like even watching the show like I could
tell you they weren't gonna end up
together so like if she didn't see that
coming like that's on you that's I'm
sorry sister that's on you
then Kendall and Joe I felt so Kendall
broke up with him then she Landon she
was like I miss him she'd lead a Chicago
brought a camera crew with her their
family in an apartment mom Joey
literally felt like the beginning of a
porno the acting was so bad they were
sitting on the couch and it's like he's
not an actor he's like a grocery store
Joe and now he's acting with this girl
like it was so uncomfortable like people
are like I'm crying Joe and kind of like
why are you crying because like the way
acting has fallen like so enough than to
bring him chemically so inauthentic and
it's like this is what happens I'm batch
I'm heart I stay figured it out you go
to bachelor paradise it is a Russian
Roulette of love maybe you'll find love
you probably won't even if you do find
love you wait until the end to find out
if the entire time the person was faking
it or not because that's what like I'm
the last day of paradise people go to
fantasy speaks they have to have
conversations about their life after
bachelor Paradise and people just break
up because they're like I'm not really
feeling it so it's like even when you
think you're in love which is hard place
to even get to imagine paradise it's
like am i dating an actor and one never
knows one never knows and I mean the
most shocking breakup was Astrid and
Kevin shocked when okay so I don't watch
but I keep up with just like the
storylines and I love Kevin Astrid and
then I start to tweet something I was
like so fun
I don't even think you guys feel bad for
me so follow me on Instagram so I can
make ad money I love you Astrid I love
you so much she got so many followers
she started the season with like 30 hey
yeah now since last night they got back
together thanks the Lord I'm so happy
why did he do that I think okay his
reasoning sort of made sense and what
she said she's so well-spoken in the
articulate and [ __ ] normal
can't a man because so many people come
on the show and you know they break like
the bleed breaks up with them they're
number two and they're like well when I
watched it back I totally understood why
they have you know their connection and
it really helped me get through the
breakup and she was like I was excited
to watch the breakup back cuz I thought
I might get some answers closure she was
like I got no answers and I really now
need to hear it from him
they had been talking and together like
since the show and toasters had seen
them at a pool together in North
Carolina which just seems like a random
place to me but whatever and so I knew
that there was like communication
there's I hadn't totally given up hope
but she was like we've been in limbo
since the show because like the trust is
broken which it is so yes they're like
still together but like how can you just
jump back into something when you
thought you were rock-solid when America
when Jackie O's thought you were
rock-solid and then Kevin just pulls the
rug out from under you so what he said
was he won his season of Bachelorette
Canada and then he won Bachelor Winter
Games with Ashley I so he was like when
Chris Harrison came and said fantasy
suite like those two words soon were
basically like PTSD like he was like I
never should have gotten to the fantasy
suite with Ashley I was a big mistake
and when I went into the fantasy he said
this before when he went into the
fantasy suite with the Bachelor Canada
he left with even more doubt but then
when he came in so I think he thought
going to the fantasy suite with Astra
was gonna be like an automatic curse and
so he like had to end it before you go
and like it's like he couldn't do it so
I kind of understood that he's been like
so open about Jude indivi tugs oh I
think they had already had sex so
because you can have like they're more
sure there are queen beds so I think it
wasn't about the sex when I moves about
like the taking of their relationship to
the next level and he just he was like I
came to Paradise with baggage and that
wasn't there to ask him like oh my god
she's just so perfect
is he your fighter fighter yes I love
and so now he's like a fire fighter so
he has like a hot ass job but he's also
like a celebrity in Toronto and so it's
like he gets the influence or benefits
while also like having a nine-to-five in
love that is sexy as hell
totally and good pension if you're a
diver and so like now they can go be the
king and queen of Toronto and be be said
she's not married to Tampa she's really
looking to relocate and you know what
I'm looking to relocate to Toronto also
so call me you guys maybe we can like do
a timeshare I love it and I know that I
should ice watch the show a few times
and I hope that she's watching now maybe
it was I'm so happy I make it work and I
so appreciate them not getting like yeah
that's right so no singing tomorrow like
that's how you know it's somewhat
because very I would say maybe like only
Carly in heaven
yeah only Carlene have a couple who
actually got married after getting
changed matters okay sorry to yeah
there's two now how many probably what
fifteen remember lace and grace right no
there has probably been like eight
engagements and Marcus and Lacey did
sort of get married ish it was all
really fishy but like they had a really
cute relationship there's no but like
they weren't a fake relationship they
really gave it a go and I consider that
a real successful and then Raven and
Adam are just like the greatest love
story of our time and the fact that they
refuse to like it's real it makes me
know that it's even like more real and
Margo and I were talking about this last
night like they shouldn't got engaged in
paradise but they don't need to because
he's a prominent businessman so he
doesn't need the Neil Lane ring but you
know getting engaged on TV can give them
each a couple hundred more hundred
thousand more Instagram followers which
is just good in the long run you just
never know where how these things are
gonna go but I really appreciate them
just taking their relationship at a
normal pace and they're so young like
let them live yeah right now it's normal
and they're that was like when Kaitlyn
and Shawn
after about sure everyone's like waiting
any married if you think about it
they've only known each other for two
years
well three years well no no I'm saying
but like back then yeah and we're like
you're not getting married in it's like
let them live for sure but three years
now like no now that you get it's crazy
I love it when Kaitlyn and Shawn met
like I didn't know Zach so in that time
like we've had a very long relationship
Ben and gay like you know what I mean so
it's I'm ready for you but it's just
like everyone like Lauren and are like
they will have known each other for a
year when they get married and that's
beautiful lovely I love them but also
the bachelor is like and not the
bachelor it's so much but the bachelor
in paradise like it's an accelerated
time I mean she everyone without makeup
at they're worse they're smelliest so
like if you fall in love with them for
real you love them for who they are yeah
if you can love Mexico you can love them
if you can love them with crabs you can
love him at home next bachelor story
that broke this weekend was Amanda
Stanton was arrested for domestic
violence in Vegas at a lit a sponsor
party and she has a dress she has
released a statement so the story came
out yesterday that she was at about
Europe at with I mean it looked so
forward was a verb ease with no they
live in Vegas but I want to go there
okay with Lauren B it looks so fun
chills whole weekend was so fun and they
kept saying like why don't we come to
Vegas more now you know why now you know
why and apparently there was a like a
noise
playing security came up didn't wear
hotel room security came up to the room
ice probably be reading this from the
statement the whole thing that's so
fuzzing and we Amanda's boyfriend
answering the door and he was trying to
talk to security and I could so see like
myself doing this
Amanda would like push him out of the
way to like you know reason let me talk
but she's drunk Hersh of illicit like
they said it was such a strong shove set
up as they felt like lined to tell all
these arrested well just let's give the
90-pound a man a 75-foot understand my
boy somehow shoved you babies out of her
little legs she is being brought up on
domestic violence charges to a six-foot
probably 250 pound man explain physics
that you know what it's like how moms
can live babies like heart like cars off
their babies they look like that's just
the Vegas bachelorette fervor the whole
thing makes no sense she like looks so
pretty in a picture and honestly like
everyone's like this is a big scandal
like it's kind of like not that it's
funny not that two minutes it's not
funny but it's like she like issued an
apology like why we don't care you enjoy
anything does and also it's like it's a
what happens in this is so relatable no
it's really bad for girls like she's
like a nasty ex-husband
and like this gives me like Bethany
vibes she haven't asked yes they do not
get along I thought that they had
co-parent really well they don't speak O
but like I feel from what I've seen so I
just hope that he doesn't use it's like
a leverage in something but like if this
has no repercussions on her custody like
I think that this is like funny and just
like like this is Vegas story like the
crazy [ __ ] happens in Vegas this is her
statement though quote Amanda is
embarrassed in a shame this happened and
sincerely apologizes to hotel security
in the Las Vegas police department
Amanda is a gentle respectful person who
has never gotten physical with anyone
under any circumstance
he explained quote that evening she had
a few drinks at a bachelorette party
and when hotel security asked her and
Bobby to quiet down she got a bit
rambunctious Amanda gave Bobby what she
thought was a playful shove hotel
security did their job and reported the
incident to the police who in turn did
their job even though her boyfriend
Bobby Jacobs assured the police it was
not an ill intent shove ill intended
shove the police still had to do their
job which Amanda completely respects and
understands but like if Bobby didn't
want to press charges move on there were
witnesses I don't know it's not illegal
to shove someone this whole thing is so
weird and I feel like there's something
yes because these facts make no sense
but if there is but if this truly is all
the facts like everyone watch her show I
think she instagrammed on a jet with him
like they're fine yeah what the hell is
going on I don't know but if here it's
like if you see her on TV you know how
small and frail she is but then if you
see her in person like she's even more
her hair is bigger than her face like
she is so small and frail like she could
not even hurt someone if she tried like
physically the laws 8 to 5 the story
dies the laws of physics but I hope
everything like I just hope people
aren't harder now but she doesn't have a
pit like obviously she does she a DC I
was like everyone's talking about and
there's so many people like who like
Gunvor like Robbie leaving a comment and
like Josh Murray like like there's so
many people like because she's like so
pretty and like Knights like people hate
her obviously and I just feel like now
people are gonna like love to use this
as like a weapon but like crazy [ __ ]
happens in Vegas on bachelor parties and
if you've ever been you know what we're
talking about and so if this is like the
worst thing that you could have done
like a show but like you would Bobby are
fine like your vibe and your mug shot
his glam no her contour look so that her
eyes look like a little wonky but her
hair is on fleek she looks drunk but she
should be she's in Vegas on bachelorette
party she's drunk you what are you doing
in there totally like if you got a mug
shot would you smile it depends how
drunk I am right like I'm like Oh a
picture but also my drunk smile I never
smile with teeth anyway he's gonna do a
little yeah I would definitely like
smirk I would look so [ __ ] up cuz I
already look so [ __ ] up in pictures
and then I didn't even when I drink a
little yeah like just one eyes going are
you like I got like this but it wouldn't
look like in your head it would be that
but it wouldn't look like that no but
like I would try to nail like this and I
would truly be like this yeah I feel
like that's classic that's like LuAnn
like that's classic amongst everything
there's a reason why they all these mug
shots look the same and it's like I'm
sure I'm an attendant once was looking
at Lindsay Lohan's mom shop with her
friends talking about what they're much
huh face would be it could be us and
here it is you have no time to plan it
and I feel like you don't know when like
I feel like you think you're gonna be
against like a certain wall and this is
mug shot now but it happens faster than
you think because they got the DMV then
I go to the side to which like thank God
I got kind of the surgery because I
would not want my mug shot from the side
before my challenge easy neck lift and
now your mug shot ready yeah cutie
look okay
and our third Bachelor related story the
bachelor star Beckham our teen star
uselessly Becca Martinez is pregnant
the bachelor person who went on the show
not star has been dating Greyston
Leonard for seven months announced her
pregnancy Wednesday quote I was in
disbelief and thought is this really
happening she told PL I immediately
called Grayson and then we went across
the street to the Dollar Tree and bought
two more pregnancy tests they of course
were both positive so she's 20 weeks
pregnant she's 22 years old she's 22
years old and she thinks she's Kylie
Jenner with her YouTube video
announcement no one cares that much
maybe this will stop her from me so
actually I don't even like want to talk
about that I said that tomorrow I just
like so don't care yeah I know you guys
wanted us to talk about this so many
people joining I gave you subliminal
messages for the past few months we knew
she was pregnant that's okay it started
in the toasters like everything good
like everything that does and I I don't
like follow her I don't keep up with her
congratulations on this very happy time
in your life cool what's next
Mahoney okay part three part three so
and I also watch the land on my diamonds
I've I didn't finish it it was so boring
and I yeah she's like she dodges she's a
professional Dodger I know could dodge a
wrench you did dodge a question if
you're the way you can bat your head she
cannot sue and also Annie wasn't asked
it wasn't in tune all around every girl
should not have been it should've been
the one I want to chip in like tree
surges and it should have been serious
it should've been like what Betty came
back to housewives after her hiatus like
don't ya know it was weirdly started so
right serious it was no and no one was
taking it seriously and all the Giovanni
he's like I'm stupid it wasn't it wasn't
done the way I would have done it I
thought the way the BrahMos spliced of
it
reunion was weird like in this less
episode them talking about Tinsley and
Sonja which happened at the beginning of
the season I didn't even remember like
that's reading in part one material yeah
they had the best reunion as part one
well I appreciate them doing that as so
as not to like drag it out and I'm gonna
watch part 3 whether it's the best or
the worst no no like in general like I'm
always gonna watch the whole reunion
like I'm not even if it sometimes it's
like the small things that I find to be
the most interesting anyway so I hate
when they like keep teasing the big
thing and then it's leaked on you so I
appreciated that one in two words you
see and three was more so like you know
closing
up tying up some loose ends and it was
the big showdown between Carroll and
Bethany career yeah yeah [ __ ]
booyah [ __ ] like how can people dispute
facts and you know what it's like I
understood what Cara was trying to say
in a weird way she was saying Bethenny
said he tried to set me up that night
but apparently was five days later but
it's like Bethenny tried to set you up
she's a decent person she has her
largest private nonprofit in history oh
she doesn't have time to set up your sad
Harold trying to compare like her fig
screenshots with like the actual text
messages between Bethany and red scarf
was so stupid that I'm glad the text
messages from red scarf or the
screenshots which can be edited deleted
removed and taken out of context while
Bethany was on the other end of them
that was so stupid
and when they were all doing their
regrets and Cara like roundabouts didn't
have one like that was annoying like I
wish someone called her out yeah she was
like you know like I tried to make the
friendship work and you know I'm sad
about that she did [ __ ] Bethany's
lines you're not that interested in me
Bethany said that first like and get off
my jock are you [ __ ] you have not one
original line right our girls know this
whole reunion
calmate or narrative like I tried so
hard to make the friendship work but
like we watch the season Michael
Rapaport said it that it's like Bethenny
gave it her all and Carole was not
interested in that's it so now she's
taking on that role like yeah I tried to
make me seem like Daddy script
plagiarism writer girl I can't and I
shan't and like the whole Adam thing
like I could not care less I'm so
uninteresting like it's some great love
like Adam I it's so weird to me the way
that they talk about it like like
they're still in each other's lives in
blah blah blah like they met in the
winds kitchen like it was it was a nice
lay let's move on you know Oh apparently
I'm Becca I'm shaded us on reddit she
said [ __ ] the morning chosen [ __ ] the
dumb [ __ ] she went on eatin after I
told her I was pregnant I told you that
before the show Becca [ __ ] you too we
don't get so happy about it oh man I was
just gonna quote real uh Romy Michele
but I want um back to Rihanna so I was
in New York more important than fell
Carole it's selling her lingerie on
Poshmark used I well back in the day
when I used to be a fixture on Poshmark
and
I really miss it it's just so much work
for so little reward Tower was on it
she's been on it since I was on it and
like she was selling everything like
it's just and it's not there for Bethany
to say that she doesn't have a career
when she's so here you know it's just
like you can't even begin to compare the
two no and so Bethany's flying private
to Mark Cuban's birthday party in Dallas
with all the other sharks while Carol's
at home photographic news lingerie no
end like Carol saying I could stack my
resume up to Bethany's any day and then
Bethany going to do that and then people
are like we shouldn't be career shaming
where were your career shamers when
Bethenny when Carol shamed Bethany's
career and that instant that insta live
of her friend being like Skinnygirl and
then Carol saying she's unhinged
Bethany's not unhinged like no also like
I I'm not here for the war on the word
skinny or diet like okay great you don't
have to be skinny but if you want to
drink skinny girl like it's not like
she's saying everyone has to be skinny
girl like right it's an option I'm like
I'm so not here like okay you can't use
the word diet anymore but why like what
if I want to choose to go on a diet
no like are very important to a lot of
people they can help you change your
whole life save live how if you've ever
watched my 600-pound life it's just like
I'm not here for everyone like feeling
like that they have to be skinny but
like if you want to be skinny great it's
an option for everyone so you know so if
any have you ever talked about when
Carol talks about how Bethany's age
shaming her which is not a thing and
Bethany didn't even do that if that is
the thing but it's funny how I'm younger
this season they had a whole episode
about a shaming like and how it like it
was literally a joke when Liza was like
they're each shaming me like just to
like get like throw like doctrine right
so it was funny the two things about
each shaming one where it's like clearly
a joke just isn't a thing and cows
really trying to say that Bethany is an
age Shamer and Dorinda calling Bethany a
bully was like what's wrong with you
like this is when people get out of
control because then when people really
get bullied they compared it to Bethany
telling Carol she has no career like
that's not bullying that's not bullying
it's just like if you if you have a job
like then say that ya know if you have a
job you have a job if you don't you know
it's not a bullying thing it's just
stating facts stating of the facts
anyways I'm very upset that Ronnie's
over like me too but they they started
filming again did you see who the new
housewife is no they didn't announce it
but it was on Underground
blogs uh I think you told me her name is
Barbara I know her she's wild she's
perfect for the show she's a friend of
LuAnn so that'll be interesting to see
the dynamics it's like I look forward to
this fresh blood but I personally don't
think that we need it I think there was
so much there especially so much was
left unsaid between Dorinda and LuAnn
and Ramona and Bethenny like they will
never like it's just gonna be a battle
and that's the problem we're having on
OSI right now it's like we really don't
we can't take any fresh blood the wounds
are too deep and too old for you to
bring it be bringing in jejunum and her
husband who's not around OSI is so bad
it's horrible and there's no seat they
need to cut the cord but so you think
they should just cancel it I think I
don't know what if they clean slated and
brought in like I'm Anna Stan Audrina
Patridge that is the only way they can
win me back
I totally it's so bad but I record and I
don't even watch it it's so bad and when
it's on I find myself like literally
like being on a 30-minute phone call
when Vicki went on that walk with Jeana
and they discovered that Jeana is the
same age as Vicki's daughter that summed
it up for me they have no business being
on the same show either choose go oh
geez or bring in fresh blood but putting
the two of them together it's oil and
water like couldn't agree more
it makes no [ __ ] sense and I didn't
watch this past week of Dallas but I
caught up and I I'm up to where you are
dude you watching the newest episode was
like the second episode of Beaver Creek
yeah they didn't watch that one but I
watched Beaver Creek and you're a
hundred percent right and I just like
it's so I can't explain why it's even so
good it's like nothing's even happened
yet
but because like Cameron is still
outrageous and then in this new episode
which I won't spoil for you but they
wake up and like you think that she's
like you know it was so no no no she's
Ashley Jacobs it's so crazy she's so out
of control and Leanne is getting out of
control because Deandra and Brandi are
becoming good friends and it's like so
cute they've the best friendship and
Leon Canyon wait Thien Truong Brandi
yeah they make up on the slopes and they
spend the day together and then the next
episodes are the rodeo together but like
I also Stephanie and Leon are becoming
good friends and it's like I want them
all to be friends except Cameron me too
totally but that's not a show and carry
like Carrie is responsible for Cameron
and she takes that burden seriously and
like they all go with snowmobiling like
she has to go with Cameron and it's just
like carries so much better than Cameron
she's a really good friend to camera
it's like you only need to do that in
season one like now she she's older she
got her second season like her own I
don't know maybe like they're really
actually friends in the community or
something like you never know what goes
on like maybe she's a Saints like go to
school together so maybe she's a patient
a big high-paying one so the TV in our
bedroom it hasn't been mounted yet
because there's like this electrical
thing and we have a stand for it
and then put it like up on the stand and
I cleaned it and I'm in the living room
I st. now you're like the biggest crash
of 2018 and I'm like I've been birthed
the TV and I come in like the TV's
cracked I've never seen a cracked TV I'm
gonna do TV
literally like I don't have money like I
literally can't shop buying furniture
like my budget is done you're at your
budget I'm at my budget and Ben just
made us play another [ __ ] 50-inch TV
well you can I know I was a good to be
the nicest TV in the land like there are
some really good deals like well now I
don't need we should back to Walmart
when we were in condos for a TV I don't
need one with Netflix cuz I have a fire
stick that like changed my life but this
was an LG Smart TV that before I got the
pocket stick it has everything but so
then I had it like twice I've never
looked twice in the living room like
it's so stupid I wish I could just get a
TV pay less cuz I don't need the Netflix
but I still want like the high quality
visuals you know the 4k you should look
into what I have because I have that I
have an Apple TV and it doesn't like now
I only have one Netflix with my Apple TV
like I don't have that so you bought
doesn't have the Netflix look at all
good TVs have no these days I'm but I'm
paying for it I don't even need it
I understand I love my fire stick um we
have to talk about Sierra bar just as
was it but before you do I just want to
talk about model school I'd like really
quickly because the way that they're
doing it if it was filmed a year ago at
Fashion Week and now they're doing it
like binging every single night is a new
episode during Fashion Week so it's like
really enjoyable to watch cuz I'm like
white right when you're into it like
there's three or more episodes for you
and it's really interesting and I think
you should watch it like I've seen the
first episode they really pull back the
curtain I'm like the modeling world and
like people are really honest about like
the scenes some of them of the know some
of them are boring cherry shake is the
only person who's honest she's like
these parties aren't fun I can't drink
and I'd work the next day no so some of
them are really honest and the ones who
like talk more are getting like the most
pie like Olivia culpo it's like I'm so
in love with her she's literally so
perfect and beautiful but like I've
never like realized
like her struggles like not struggles
but I used to think she goes to sleep at
night like not a care in the world but
like she's gonna give so much more he
keeps her up in them right she really is
so much shorter than the rest of the
girls and there's nothing she can do
about it she really won't know like not
like a plight like that but like there's
like really like she wants to be a
high-fashion model she's five six that's
not gonna happen great but she's five
six and she's also a sister and she
makes more money than other girls she
doesn't revolve and gets paid fifty
thousand dollars for an Instagram post
right so I'm then treated her Sports
Illustrated she welcome we're working
for ten years and it's fifty thousand
Instagram followers right but then she
like does Sports Illustrated she gets
her ass handed to her literally it's
crazy she just didn't know she goes to
start a restaurant with her dad gets her
ass handed her again she just keeps
getting out that I'm like wow look I'm
like who could I've never thought anyone
could yell at Olivia COPO but now I'm
like I really feel like I'm seeing her
life like I feel and then with a
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show it's like
did she try to no no no but like the
models who did it's like not all of them
made it they were like really honest and
like Nadine was talking about how she
tried out the past two years she
literally fainted last one to the
hospital last year because of all the
stress of it and like that she wasn't
eating and like you say it was because
she wasn't even she said yeah she said
she was like working out and I'm pretty
sure she said she wasn't and there's
some there's some girls who it's like oh
she's like me she eats pizza and
whatever and it's like lucky you but
like there are some models who really
cannot lead salads and they're pretty
honest about it they're like I'm not
eating at the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Week and Victoria Secret Fashion Show
casting week so it a really pulled back
the curtain on a lot of things and like
the money making so like Caroline who is
a commercial model so like the hi shop
fashion models probably look down on her
and she's other kind of girl she would
have a complex about it cuz a lot of the
commercial models are trying to get into
high fashion she was like the money
isn't commercial to the point I choose
an ad for Kohl's Macy's that's fifty
thousand dollars I make in one day
Wow like and the walking abreast with
Owens should be on the show walking a
runway you don't get paid like you get
paid that dirt unless you're like a
Bella or Gigi a baby like 30 grand and
then in LA and one of the other episodes
and then in tonight's episode they
talked a lot about like diversity in the
modeling industry and like it's becoming
like a really big like contentious like
sheds some of the girls
you saw that clip and it's like it's
really real like and like worried see is
like the show is made by IMG so it's all
IMG Models part of WME and that's why
Olivia's on it because she's no actually
she's the CAA yeah that's so interesting
that isn't she doesn't have a modeling
agency
not an IMG model but anyways it's like
IMG is like pulling back the curtain on
like all the different varying aspects
in the modeling industry including
diversity you know it's like they're not
censoring that conversation was
absolutely horrible to watch when I
catch yes she Nina and ping were just
like talking about the strides as being
Asian and black in the modeling industry
and that like for years they couldn't go
to Milan because they literally wouldn't
have let black girls walk in the runway
shows and Devon was like I mean like as
a blonde like I understand no well in a
later scene Devon says like their
sittings aren't far apart from each
other and she thought they were just
talking about like struggles in the
modeling I don't like just making it so
when she was like I lived in Paris for
two years on my own a didn't speak the
language like that's what she was trying
to say but she didn't hear that they
were talking about diversity
specifically you know just coming up as
a model yeah and then in tonight's
episode they have like all a sleepover
together and it's like these girls
aren't all friends they're just cast
mates so like it's more yeah it's gonna
get like they get into it again but like
Devon is far and away the most
successful model on the show and it's
like oh yeah she's walked in Everett
she's done like the biggest campaigns
well she is the same agent as Gigi
Louise Matos but Hannah Ferguson has the
same hell as Louise also or she said the
Wiis on the phone I can't imagine
they're in that many Louise modeling
agents and I mean she didn't get
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show right no
but it's obviously like everything that
Gigi says no Gio
Devon looks really similar and they give
it to Devon right and like Devon just I
mean and I'm sure she knows this but
like she's gotten really like like she's
having the baby words she said she's
been this is her sixth year in the
victorious you know she is great a great
manager agent and great luck great luck
because like she's not like different
looking she's just like All American she
like that's why anything Gigi doesn't
get like I'm sure they just pass up so
great and being friends with all those
girls it's like you know anyways so
she's gonna have to answer she gets
engaged though does happen on the show I
don't think so cuz it happened like they
stopped filming I can't imagine they
film past the New Year because like it's
for New York Fashion Week yeah and the
way that they're doing it it's like
they're trying to compete with Netflix
like binging and it's working for me
oh the you know so they do it whatever
every night of the week so it started on
last week on Monday and then every night
there's a new episode and Fashion Week
is happening now so like you really look
like you're getting a sense of like what
Fashion Week is about and I just want to
say I'm like here for it and I think
it's a really good and interesting show
and I hope that it gets another season
because I love Olivia and her looks like
she never she never sleeps on a look
I've been watching I think some of her
side interviews like annoying she's like
trying really hard to prove that she has
a personality cuz models the stereotype
like they don't personality so she's
like trying X try to be like extra and I
find it annoying I agree well so I'm
just bitter so these girls are skinny
and rich and like how much she's really
well let's move in but she was like when
she was getting her makeup done Monday
they were talking about how she got a
spot in trainwreck the Amy Schumer movie
and her agent was like have you ever
done comedy before her and like of
course yes and she's like every day of
my life that's it
it was funny and it was like off the
cuff so like meet like some of them are
pretty funny like Caroline's funny
Hannah's funny ping is funny I like ping
and it's like I wouldn't think models
crying Nadine is like really sweet when
she got Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
she's sitting on her bed calling shanyna
and like she is just like bursting with
joy and she's like alone who personally
this is her first one she and like
seditious her I've met her she's
literally lovely and like then she talks
about how she date how it's hard to date
being a model she dated Harry Styles and
she's to get like fan mail to her
apartment with exes over her face and
they talk about like dating Harry Styles
oh my god has any of the other things
you're watching this why do you go out
with Caroline's brother Caroline brought
her brother to an event to meet meeting
she said she wants to like date a nerd
he works at IBM and he's so hot like
beautiful he could be a model too I'm
the girl with the boyfriend
Caroline no you need to watch the rest
of it she's not dead she's what he does
come on sad but like hey little friends
like annoy me get off the show like he
has side in Andrews he gets makeup no if
you watch more like I think you'll like
him more he's okay like you and he like
does a campaign for Jeep Wrangler and he
was like they're literally paying me to
like hook up a bike and go through the
like the mountains he's like that's what
I want to do on my day off anyway
they're really cute and he apparently
was like a big football player at Ole
Miss he's like someone who's just born
under a lucky star totally Keith
Hutchinson like he was one I mean a star
football player at Mississippi and now a
male model I could could your life be
easier so and every time they go back to
Mississippi he's like a celebrity like
the biggest star there and she's like oh
mr. Heath Hodgins
that's you they're really cute anyways
that is my endorsement for model squad
Tara Burgess so people like are like
it's the next the boys
Netflix is putting so much money behind
it they literally like or shoving it up
my ass
like I went to Netflix to watch it and
they was right there buddy I would just
watch friends because I'm not the TV I
was on my computer and it was there I'm
like oh I should watch it like for
research and I just love those movies
I'm like there was no way
I wasn't gonna like it but I didn't I
liked it like I enjoyed it I thought it
was cute it had cute moments when they
were like some of the like texting stuff
I feel like the texts were like very
real like I like it's not Mia because
you can't face time with an Android
that's important to know you can't no
but that was hilarious when they were
facetiming and lag so here's the thing I
know everyone loves that girl barb and I
don't watch but she was Ethel mugs I
loved her as Ethel people use barb
yes she's so nice she was an absolutely
horrible actress in this movie I was not
buying what she was selling for 10
seconds nobody end she's like this
protagonists are supposed to feel bad
for her I guess she dated in the end she
is a loser anyway in the beginning you
were supposed to feel bad for a Mike she
was so mean to her mom her mom did
nothing to her except give her a
wonderful life and she's like some eater
mom she's like literally hates her mom
because her mom's like pretty and skinny
and like gzl syndrome I think you know
what it's like to go to school and be
like bigger and I'm like well first of
all that's a personal choice like if you
I would just quit being bigger and I
love to it like it's a personal choice
so if you want to be they graded you
know don't like she was me can seem like
it was her mom's fault that like she was
fat like it's not like that was really
frustrating and she's like Sony to her
mom and I just hated her from the get-go
she like took all of her like
insecurities out on her mom where it's
like it's like your mom's fault that you
don't like the way that you look like
you're a pretty girl as a character she
was inconsistent because some of the
things that she did it's like she's
confident she doesn't care like when she
tells Veronica like you meant Quasimodo
and she walks out like her [ __ ] don't
say no and then but it's like that same
person like wouldn't treat their mom
that way like or just like she would say
with ramen or the look at the first
couple scenes but she was so evil like
Roenick evolved like an wash and yes she
was evil but it was like she was doing
all these things because like her mom
was like making Krissi nuts was making
her think that these were the things
that are important in this world and
like she I mean Veronica I've been
through a lot like her family life is
annoying like she goes to school and
she's [ __ ] pissed no Veronica like
stay out of her way
Veronica had good reason to be like a
little bit of a [ __ ] but like Sierra
did not she have the perfect home life
her house was I would kill for that yeah
her parents had a loving marriage her
dad's [ __ ] famous they're rich like
she's straight A's like she really had
no nothing to be upset about no and it's
like I was waiting for the moment in the
movie
where you know Sierra Veronica get close
and then they go to school in Veronica
like ditches her and Sierra realizes
that they don't have a real friendship
and that never happened Veronica never
did that to her anything
the only time someone did someone was
when Sierra dissed Veronica like
Veronica I thought she just has a
character she was just so evolved and so
much more than meets the eye and I
wanted happiness for her and I wanted
her and of course young Jaime why didn't
they smell Jaime like that it was it was
Jerry the whole time like why did they
have to do that it was okay I didn't
like the most pivotal scene is when she
pretends to be deaf we're like these
little brothers deaf it's like obviously
close to him and she like mocks at and
and they never even addressed here he
and they juggle a lot of flack for that
like in the deaf community of course
yeah just a fucked-up thing to do it was
it was very weird that was like so
towards the end like they want you to
think Sierra but just as a loser like
from the start she wasn't she emerges
not a loser no she was cool in the
beginning and she became a loser like
what she did to Veronica at the game
like what a piece of [ __ ] like ronica
was nothing but nice to her and yang you
forced these two people to like kiss and
be together and there's two like cute
nice people also I'm sorry just the most
unrealistic ending and I know that for
good like the message of the movie I
really got behind like it was like you
don't have to be like the coolest
prettiest girl in school to like get the
guy and it's like there's so much more
to high school then looks like and I was
really there for the message but they
got there in the most absurd unrealistic
way that like they were they were gonna
do anything to make their message come
through yeah and to make the two of them
end up together and it's like one they
didn't even show us the pivotal
conversation between Veronica and Jaime
but wait when Jaime opened the door and
Veronica turns around in that gray dress
like scanner and like I wanted them to
be together yeah but it's like then he
would only be with her because of her
personality Monica became like really
was a good person led me could have
liked and by the way like Steve what was
her boyfriend's name I oh I always spend
spent like that was just like a weird
subplot like an unnecessary one yeah
also the greatest character damn her
friend oh my god she was so [ __ ] mean
to and all he want he was in love with
her they never address after he was in
love with her he was totally he was like
I love you I love you and she wouldn't
say back but like hey there was a little
truth behind that and then he took
personal offense like not even as a
like as a lover when she like wouldn't
talk to him anymore cuz she was like I'm
like when you go to a party with
Veronica like you don't have to lie and
say you're saying in one voice damn why
don't you say either I'm out with
Veronica like you're allowed to have
another friend or to invite him he would
have crushed it up right he's the best
personality he's like a party he's
handsome you need a nice girl he would
crush it I can test I thought he was so
funny and everywhere that he was my
favorite part of the movie man the
teacher just like a teacher oh my god
the teacher she was so funny but your
horrible personality like she was great
and they were just like great nuggets
that like we should be stuck with Sierra
what a [ __ ] sour puss on the whole
movie I was so sick of her the movie was
great except for Sierra Burgess yeah and
no Sierra but the titles true of Sierra
Burt just is a loser yeah because she
ended up a big [ __ ] loser and justice
for Veronica
I want to spin off of Veronica's life
justice for Jaime like honestly he
looked way cuter as Peter come in ski
and I'm not in love with Jaime
whatsoever and the movie wasn't even
about him it's like they throw him in
there so people would watch it and like
they put up one scene with his belly
like wasn't they fill in the movie
before he wasn't a handsome guy yeah
yeah but now he's like oh he's gonna be
in everything I'm supposed to be like a
nerd I sort of got it like with his
weird friend right and they're like
virgins and they were like talking about
like losery stuff so when they were
climbing the rope in gym class they were
so obviously on harnesses they like
weren't even holding on to the ropes I
couldn't even think I'm like this is
such [ __ ] like you're not even on
the rope they were pretending to pull up
and they were being pulled by harnesses
I'm like their asses were in the air
from the harness it was so stupid it was
really like it was a low-budget I wasn't
I do not like it but as far as like
movies go these days like I enjoyed it
thoroughly and I want more movies like
that you know
I mean it looks like they're Cedars I
didn't see a movie all summer because
there was nothing to eat it goes like
this to all the boys I look before
kissing booth savages I'm too much SPF
18 apparently computer Kaminsky Zinta -
but is it an F looks original if it's
not I'm not interested
is it worse than sierra burgess oh right
like if because if the roles were
reversed like oh my god that was so not
okay yeah that's all in no world does
anyone that's stupid and they wouldn't
realize first I was I was actually
laughing they've kind of like the way
that they did the date like I never
thought that I was like oh he'll have to
go on this date and like he'll realize
that in Chile perhaps whatever but they
really like played it out to the end I
totally thought she was gonna get caught
when she's like texting her things to
say like that was weird but she
literally like they got away with the
kiss and yes it was non-consensual and
it was inappropriate and it was
inappropriate I completely agree but it
was actually kind of funny like and cute
how they did all that also when he sends
her the picture and she doesn't know
what to send back and she sends the
elephant like that's something I would
have done you know so she obviously like
had a good personality but like nobody I
thought the texting like the way that so
many movies get texting wrong and I felt
like the way they're meaner than Android
also it doesn't do the dog whatever okay
having a technological part I don't care
about like the way that kids text these
days it's like some 40 year old man like
can't write that but they did a really
good job that's why the the Netflix
young adult movies do so well is because
they capture high school so well like in
kissing booth when they went to that
party like she was dancing on the table
with her shirt off and was drunk like
that happens that party it's like they
capture high school very well but this
movie was just like so like so but so
bad I don't think it was so bad I would
I would say you should watch it cuz a
lot of people really liked it
I enjoyed it it wasn't like the greatest
movie but also like I was just I need to
stop like I hate all the hype around
these movies it's like you can't form
your own opinion like everyone like this
is better like in the opinion of Sierra
Burgess was that it was like this epic
next to otherwise Bella before and I
watched it it wasn't so I'm able to form
my own opinion no like just I I just
wanted to be able to enjoy a movie
without having to like is it the next is
it the greatest drink like her dad just
like kept quoting what women like stop
yeah like do you say anything other than
book quotes like she needs a dad right
knocking not an author no not like a
writer girl totally Kalra as well should
have played the mom that would actually
been really cute yeah it would
I'm just like the crazy nuts of it all I
couldn't she crushed it when she came
back with those to the junk food and she
was like I'm eating whatever I want mom
I'm like yes Rama do you know so like
she got pop chips like she'll be okay
totally I mean she was so beautiful like
and so now if I were on Instagram and
she's just like the social activists we
need she's out here like supporting
mental health awareness day national
suicide prevention day like she is just
like a true artist beautiful inside and
out yeah she's last so now that the show
played Margot Robbie yeah but like high
school yeah
ethereal I hope she gets more roles she
should wait actress too yes because I
bought her being a [ __ ] and I also
bought her be nice
yeah and diverse all of her looks except
like what I don't like is like when she
was down in the dumps
and she like wore a sweater with her
hair looking olympos [ __ ] like she
Veronica wouldn't have done that like
Veronica would have like came to school
looking even better than ever and
sitting alone and being fabulous not
being like a Sierra Burgess their
friendship was like so cute though they
really Veronica when she became nice
made me like Sierra and that's the only
moment I like Sierra would you came up
during all she was expense per company
and she was like such a good friend like
ran to the bathroom on no time obviously
she had to leave Jenna in the dust like
Jenna could've been helpful and when she
went to the party with her like she was
a good friend throughout like she never
ever did she never wavered she yeah like
right she could have she could have
ditched Sierra at the party
and she didn't originally she'd left to
go make out with her right hand which
was the problem yeah she didn't do
anything wrong by doing that no and you
could've been so mean to Sierra when
Sierra I was like will you help me
catfish this guy and I'll help you would
get back cuz I honestly Sierra needed
Veronica Veronica did not need Spence
Spencer was not gonna realize she learnt
read a book and was like right like that
part was stupid so like Sierra really
needed Veronica and she could have been
made and left in her face and she didn't
write and also what was I gonna say
about Veronica also Veronica could have
stolen Jaime and she should have gone on
the date driven like lost Sierra and
then like made out with him and it was
so cute like these first West I was
loving oh my god I need a spin-off where
Jaime breaks up a Sierra and gets back
together with also how they did in the
end like with like like a finale of
Housewives where they gave blurbs I
don't like they're gonna make it work
long distance I actually don't like
those blurbs about not true movies like
you just made that up
no those that has to be reserved for
like the final episode of OC I mean I
mean I'm sorry Oh J like true story true
story it's like a preppy connection like
look at what happened to him I don't
need to see like what the on LaVon the
Polka King which is only V of the week I
really of the week which is a great play
nobody watched it because we just had
such a busy week but now we're back
we're here make sure to watch the poll
okay it's a Netflix original so it's
free it's with Jack Black it's a [ __ ]
hilarious movie we really enjoyed it
we'll discuss it at the end of the week
story for the choice movie of the week
yes well after an hour and a half of
talking nonstop is there anything else
we missed I don't know he was such a we
haven't sat in these chairs in a week
like it was such a whirlwind of a week
and I've never been more grateful for
Rosh Hashanah oh it's a starry night
everyone happy new year new year new me
next week we have a very exciting week
it is Yom Kippur so we're off Wednesday
Wednesday but Thursday we have Leeanne
Locken Thursday the 20th and then the
21st the next day we have Jerry
O'Connell coming on who I love for so
many reasons he's my got to tell him he
spoke at my NYU initiate like the first
day that's so crazy they're not coming
together anymore no we were had them on
the same day but they needed separate
days like and he needed separate days
but then I also went on watch I was like
he was talking about how much he loves
Leeanne and they wonder if they met
before they could have met on our show
okay well whatever so Jerry will be here
talking about his new men a name did
they play by like it because they kept
saying miramount about real men watch
Bravo they literally would say in every
every episode of watch it up inside but
then I'm Malou an episode they didn't
say it once and they said clay Bravo
played by places like real men watch
Bravo I was like in this day and age I
don't think you could say that you think
I think that might have had something to
do I don't think so I feel like it's
like so cute it's a little controversial
it's like real men wear pink so Jerry
will be here on Friday discussing a new
show next Friday I'm really excited
because they they cast it now and they
have Michael yo who I love Margaret oh
no you weren't there when I was in st.
Louis in the dressing room in my show he
was at the show before I me like crossed
paths in the dressing room he was like
so nice and cool it was he that he's
young he is he the style of the set a
person no I think he's straight he's
like dude dude like he's cool if you saw
a picture of him you would know okay
he's like he's hot and look forward to
seeing the format of the show and and
every other show that they just kind of
like throw into the wind these days yeah
maybe when their shows that already
exists with great formats one of these
days I'll do the toast I can carry on
for an hour and a half
I mean kam tous has given me enough to
live I'm dead I enjoy until Memorial Day
weekend we have to go home and start
planning Campos 2.0 thank you all so
much for being here sorry about
the choppy September it's gonna be a
little bit more chopping because of
holidays and just like general life
things try and be cool with us I know
it's really easy for you guys to
complain and I appreciate that I do as a
complainer myself I totally understand
but just like bear with us they say what
do you want us to fast and do the toast
it just doesn't it's just not gonna
happen
so we're here Wednesday Thursday Friday
this week Monday I'm not here but we are
doing the show yes-no Tuesday the 18th
is Lauren Elizabeth is coming she's
closing with Jackie that'll be really
good cuz she's like a toaster and like a
famous person and a personality and
friends with Joey King you have to ask
her about that right and we'll just make
this seamless experience oh you need
someone on Monday to Monday I'm in
Puerto Rico to meet Ben's one-year
wedding anniversary I have a good excuse
oh and speaking of your wedding
anniversary on Friday we are doing a
wedding anniversary themed show with
Anthony Vasquez close my wedding
photographer and it's gonna be yours and
did my engagement so he's gonna be
sharing some of the most premium photos
from Claudia's wedding to celebrate your
one-year have been it's been so fast
really honestly like I feel like if Ben
and I made it to this year we can make
it through anything this was the hardest
year of my life because well people say
the first year of marriage is the
hardest nothing to do with my butt it's
like if you this year my personal and
business life was very difficult and Ben
was like trying trying ride-or-die like
so helpful bummy a ring the day I lost
my job which was just irresponsible but
whatever I love him for it and it was
around already he already had and I try
was gonna reprimand him but it was so
sweet and loved him and then also CEO
guys yoga oh my god such I really I did
have an emotional surface animal this
year so I feel I feel very like there
are a lot of things that are uneasy in
my life but my marriage is not one of
them I feel very strong about it that is
so beautiful it is it's the best so
thanks again recommend married life oh
for sure ten out of ten I mean just when
you have a lot of things going on in
your life like going on dates and like
finding a man it's not something I could
it could add to my list right now right
so I'm so grateful to have like the most
stable wonderful man in my life I'm
happy for you Theo
yeah of course um thank you all so much
for tuning in we are the morning toast
the Millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
time on Facebook and YouTube YouTube
preferred we're gonna eventually gonna
migrate over to YouTube so make sure to
make a youtube account subscribe like us
on Facebook we're starting a premium
content on our Instagram at the morning
toast and I'm gonna twitter at the
morning toast also if you're a commuter
you know you can't tune in every day
you live on the west coast the podcast
app is for you the morning shows the
podcast app leave us five stars write a
nice review you guys so maybe we can get
to the top and beat Joe Rogan that's
Jimmy we may still want to beat
felonious Florida but they've fallen off
the charts and we used to want to be on
Anna Faris ever again
so now we're gonna be Joe Rogan yes one
time I want to be Joe Rogan but if you
haven't left us a positive podcast
review go ahead and do it it takes no
time out of your day and it actually
really helps us it does so thank you all
so much we love you so much we will see
you tomorrow
follow me Jackie oh problems